les américains et les européens ne
semblent plus croire au dialogue avec
poutine une quarantaine de pays est
actuellement représentée en allemagne au
coeur des discussions donc les
équipements militaires à livrer aux
combattants ukrainien washington croit
en la victoire de la résistance nous
allons remuer ciel et terre assuré le
ministre américain de la défense lloyd
austin on attend d'un instant à l'autre
sa déclaration que l'on suivra sur
france 24 des américains ont déjà
débloqué 3 milliards 400 millions d'eads
militaire pour kiev et puis les
allemands aussi changent de stratégie
annonce pour la première fois l'envoi de
blindés de type guépards et léopard
pascal thibaux à berlin
critiqué depuis plusieurs semaines déjà
pour ses réticences à livrer des arts en
général et spécialement des armes
lourdes donc ce matin lors de la
conférence de ramstein ouest du pays la
ministre de la défense a confirmé des
informations de presse l'allemagne est
prête à accepter la livraison de chars
départ qui sont spécialisées dans la
défense aérienne c'est-à-dire qui
permettre concrètement abattre des
hélicoptères ou des avions ce qui serait
utile effectivement en ukraine en raison
des nombreuses attaques aériennes de
l'armée russe on ignore le nombre de
chars dont il s'agit il y a deux mois le
fabricant qui valait ray est cédée à
l'ukraine et bien avait parlé de 50
chars voilà de quoi il s'agit et puis il
ya aussi deux demandes qui ont été
déposées auprès du gouvernement allemand
par une autre société allemande
fabriquant des armes pour d'autres chars
il s'agit au total d'un volume de
environ 200 véhicules en attente sur ces
dossiers la réponse de gouvernement